all right now to this story we've been
following the Attorney General of
Missouri is defending a new
investigation of sex abuse within the
Catholic Church even though he'll have
to rely on the cooperation of church
leaders Missouri is the first state to
announce an investigation into clergy
abuse since Pennsylvania released a
scathing grand jury report last month
that report identified more than three
hundred abusive priests and more than
one thousand child victims over seven
decades Niki batiste is here with the
new push for investigations Nicki good
morning good morning top row top
prosecutors in multiple states tell CBS
News they're reviewing the Pennsylvania
report and considering options for their
own investigations but different states
have different laws over how far they
can go we visited Missouri where some
victims advocates worry a new
investigation won't have the teeth
needed to get to the truth they're
meeting for the first time but for
decades Michael Sandridge and Joe
Eldridge shared a painful connection for
the two of you at your lowest point what
did that look like it looked like a rope
around my neck and me sitting on the
windowsill ready to jump I'd be driving
in a car and think of if I hit the
bridge and I get killed that way then I
don't have to think about anything
Sandridge says he couldn't think about
the abuse he endured in the early 1970s
starting at the age of 10 when he says a
priest molested him I'm crying the whole
time he goes why are you crying and I
couldn't even answer and because you
have to stop that nothing happened this
is anything wrong this is how special
friends react another priest Monsignor
Thomas O'Brien allegedly helped
facilitate the abuse by supplying
alcohol and drugs a decade later
Eldred claims O'Brien was one of three
priests who sexually abused him starting
around the age of nine he had me perform
oral sex on him and then threatened that
if I ever told anyone I would be kicked
out of the church and
my parents would disown me I'd lose my
family and that I'd go straight to hell
the Diocese of Kansas City st. Joseph
allegedly received multiple warnings
over several years about troubling
behavior by O'Brien including a letter
from a nun who reported his extremely
heavy drinking after an allegation of
sexual misconduct with a minor in 1983
the diocese sent him to a residential
treatment facility but allowed him to
return the following year to a limited
ministerial assignment the Church
finally removed him from ministry in
2002 he died
eleven years later we're not going to
pull our punches Missouri Attorney
General Josh Holley recently announced
the first statewide investigation into
clergy sex abuse since a Pennsylvania
grand jury report identified hundreds of
predator priests we have an obligation
to the public to get all of the facts
and to lay them out and that is exactly
what we are going to do lawyer Rebecca
Randall's estimates there are thousands
of victims across Missouri she's
skeptical of whether the Attorney
General can conduct a thorough
investigation is that enough no and the
reason it's not enough is because the
investigation that's being looked at by
the Attorney General doesn't have
subpoena power unlike the grand jury in
Pennsylvania Holly's investigation won't
be able to force the church to hand over
its documents Holly says under Missouri
State law only local prosecutors can
issue subpoenas or convene grand juries
so he's relying on assurances from
church leaders like st. Louis Archbishop
Robert Carlson any files that they want
to see will be available to them can you
really trust all the diocese to turn
over all of their documents to you well
if they don't then we'll make that fact
known you want to believe folks when
they say they're gonna cooperate but you
have to see what do you want the
Missouri Attorney General to do open up
everything
Michael Sandridge and Joe Eldridge
settled lawsuits with the church in 2014
in an email to CBS News the diocese says
their specific claims were not
officially investigated but we do
believe them to be
victims of clerical sexual abuse it
needs to be an honest investigation if
anybody's going to heal from this if the
church is going to heal then they need
to rip that band-aid off and open it up
clean that wound out for all to see
it'll be ugly it's going to be nasty but
it needs to happen the Kansas City
Bishop has said he's happy to cooperate
with the Attorney General's
investigation
the diocese notes that today any priest
would be immediately removed at the
first credible allegation and we
actually called all 50 states talk to
all the attorneys general's offices many
of them have called the Pennsylvania
Attorney General saying how do we do
this how do we open an investigation
because many of those states had priests
from the Pennsylvania report passed
through at one time so widespread and so
sickening the more you hear the worse it
gets
yes this is going on we're more as well
continue well we'll be talking to you
again soon Nicki thanks